[Music]
there are quite a few really scary
places in our universe
most of them are cold worlds with no
chances of life
ever evolving there but even among all
this gloomy diversity
some objects can be singled out that may
rightfully be called the most dangerous
exoplanets ever discovered by now
and today i invite you to check out the
most
incredible ones
[Music]
shortly before halloween in 2020 nasa
compiled a list of the most
terrifying worlds among others they
included
six exoplanets each of these objects
environments
is not just extremely harsh for any
living organism
even finding oneself in their
comparatively close proximity
may prove to be fatal the first object
on the list is a black gas giant
designation tres 2b
this celestial object orbits the star
tre s2
which is a yellow dwarf lying as far as
718 light years away from us
let's take a closer look at it due to
some unique properties of the chemical
composition of the surface of tres 2b
the planet absorbs over 99 of all the
light shed on it
the nature of these properties remains a
mystery
and chances are there are some chemical
reactions taking place on the surface
that we have never registered on any
similar object before
and it is these properties that make
tres 2b
the darkest exoplanet on the
astronomical map of today
this gas giant was discovered on the
21st of august 2006
with more details on its characteristics
obtained several years later
the mass of tres 2b is 1.2 jupiter
masses
and its radius measures 1.27 times that
of jupiter
the atmosphere is as scorching as 1000
degrees celsius
which gives the exoplanet a faint red
glow like that of ambis
still in spite of its gloomy looks tres
2b
doesn't really qualify to be called the
most dangerous place in the universe
there are many more objects lurking in
space that are more terrifying than that
let's see some more inhospitable ones
here is another exoplanet designation 55
cancri e it lies in the system of a
sun-like star
designation 55 cancri a
this celestial object was discovered on
the 30th of august 2004 by the doppler
spectroscopy method
let's look at it in more detail the
planet's mass
equals approximately eight earth masses
and its radius
measures 1.875 that of the earth
55 concrete e is tidally locked
and so it is always daytime on one side
and night time on the other
that is why the side facing the host
star is always heated up to a
temperature reaching 2400 degrees
celsius
with the temperature on the night side
1300 degrees celsius
these values are so high because the
distance between the planet
and its parent star is just 0.0183
astronomical units besides
volcanism on 55 cancri e which is
thought likely to be there
causes dust clouds emissions these
clouds trap heat
and effectively prevent it from escaping
into space
the planet's orbital period is slightly
under 18 hours
as for the atmospherical makeup there is
helium and hydrogen registered in it
there are also large amounts of carbon
incidentally
this element is likely to form thick
layers of graphite and diamonds in the
planet's interior
55 cancri e isn't the only object in the
planetary system of its host star
there are four other celestial objects
orbiting it
the environments on these are by far
more hospitable
which is the feature by which the 55
cancri a system
differs from the following object it is
dubbed
poltergeist or psr 1257 plus 12c
this is an exoplanet lying in a pulsar
system
the celestial object is located just
0.36 astronomical units from the
system's center
this shows that poltergeist wouldn't
have survived a supernova
that must have taken place before the
pulsar had been formed
consequently the exoplanet is likely to
have formed
after this tremendous event with the
material for it coming from the nebula
left after the explosion according to
another hypothesis
the pulsar may have formed after the
merging of two white dwarfs
unlike with a supernova this process
isn't always accompanied by a powerful
blast
still as this is the first object of its
kind we have discovered
science cannot give a definite answer as
to its origins
the system with a celestial object lies
300 light years from the earth its mass
is approximately four times that of our
planet
as for its orbital period it is around
66 days
incidentally the outstandingly powerful
radiation emitted by the pulsar is
enough to crumple
any spaceship wanting to approach the
mysterious exoplanet
in its system even with all these
properties taken into account
portageist does not really qualify as
the most dangerous exoplanet known to us
on approaching it an astronomical body
may simply get destroyed
but it would get positively vaporized in
close proximity to the following object
the reason for this effect is the
extremely high temperature on kepler-70b
which is the hottest exoplanet known to
us
the object orbits the sub-dwarf star
kepler-70
with a surface temperature higher than
that on our sun
it reaches 6800 degrees celsius
the object's mass equals 0.44 earth
masses
and its radius measures 0.76 that of the
earth
the celestial object's orbital period is
345 minutes
in other words a day here is less than
six hours long
interestingly the exoplanet regularly
passes another object in the system
kepler-70c at a distance of 240 000
kilometers
to date this is the closest that planets
in space have been registered to pass
each other
the extremely high temperature on
kepler-70b could be accounted for by the
fact that this object may once have been
part of its parent star
as for giving it the status of an
exoplanet it will take more evidence to
confirm that it deserves to be given it
so this remains an open question
it should be mentioned that kepler-70b
is not the only celestial
object we know of that interacts with
its parent star so closely
another object in similar conditions is
the exoplanet known as wasp
12b this celestial body
lies 870 light years away from our
system
its radius measures 1.93 times that of
jupiter
and its mass equals 1.46 jupiter masses
wasp 12b is just 0.03 astronomical units
away from its parent star
due to this close proximity the
exoplanet has a temperature reaching as
much as 2200 degrees celsius
the host stars extremely powerful
gravitation
slowly absorbs wasp-12b
eventually in approximately 10 million
years time
the exoplanet is expected to be
destroyed completely
bearing all this in mind we will
probably never delve any deeper into the
nature of this exoplanet
it would appear that studying worlds of
this kind cannot be high on scientists
list of priorities
however some of these objects may happen
to have some really unique
features seemingly quite plain and
ordinary
worlds like that may conceal many more
dangers than would appear at first
glance
when flying past the celestial body
hd189733b
for example one might complacently think
it a safe planet
as it resembles our earth by its looks
but if one were to get as low as the
level of its atmosphere
one would be exposed to some
life-threatening dangers
for a start the object's winds carry
particles of silicate
and develop velocities of 8 700
kilometers per hour
besides the rains on this planet cause
precipitations of molten glass
the reasons for such hazardous weather
conditions are extremely high
temperatures
and the atmosphere's peculiar chemical
composition
speaking about the exoplanet's orbital
period
it is approximately 2.5 days
and it is highly likely that the object
is tidally locked to its parent star
[Music]
as usual a quick overview of its main
characteristics
hd189733b is a bright blue gas giant
orbiting an orange dwarf in the
constellation vulpecular
it lies just 63 light years away from
our system
the object's diameter is 1.1 times that
of jupiter
and as for its mass it is 113
that of jupiter
interestingly the distance between
hd18973
and its star is 30 times less than the
distance between the earth and the sun
and equals approximately 5 million
kilometers
due to its close proximity to the parent
star it has a constant surface
temperature of as high as around 930
degrees celsius on the dayside
with the temperature on the night side
never dropping below
425 degrees celsius
immediately on being discovered the
celestial body became a subject of
investigations
in 2007 thanks to data obtained by the
hubble telescope
scientists found out that hd189733b
has a foggy atmosphere interestingly
when the planet transits between the
observer on the earth and its star
its atmosphere assumes a reddish hue
this effect could possibly be caused by
the haze in the atmosphere
according to preliminary estimates it
consists of particles of iron
silicates and aluminium oxide
apart from that the information beamed
back by the hubble telescope
helped scientists establish that the
planet's atmosphere contains water
vapour
neutral oxygen and an organic methane
compound
additional investigations revealed the
presence of carbon monoxide on the day
side of the planet
what prompted most questions however was
the results of investigations revealing
traces of methane of an unusual variety
in the planet's atmosphere
this chemical element was shown to be in
a peculiar fluorescent state
when it emits electromagnetic radiation
in the infrared range
this state of the substance is
indicative of some unknown activity in
the atmosphere of the exoplanet
which still remains to be found out
this is quite a clear-cut example of a
situation when investigating an
object like an exoplanet with an
exceptionally harsh environment
may yield unexpected results about some
processes
taking place there that will be a
valuable contribution to science
and as the process of studying these
worlds continues
they will remain no other than horror
planets to us
as well as a solid reminder that we are
more than just lucky
to be the dwellers of our earth
dear friends if you feel like hearing
more about other worlds like these
scattered across the universe
let me know in the comments or else
simply hit the like button
and let's keep in touch
[Music]
you